we're on a roller coaster we are on the
way up to the top of the roller coaster
you know when you're in it you're dick
dick dick dick dick dick going up to the
top and you're getting nervous about the
big plunge down on rates and we're right
at the top we're right there about to
start going down we're just not sure how
many minutes or days we have to wait
before the roller coaster starts going
down so if you're if you're an optimist
as I have to be as an investor I took
advantage of this I'm long equities and
it was the right thing to do I spent my
whole day telling people you cannot time
the market hi Mr Wonderful here and I am
small business does your company qualify
for the employee retention credit find
out at Wonder trust.com educate yourself
with a live expert at Wonder trust now
because the ERC program is going to end
soon